Gear for La.
It is a bummer.
How about Holly a?
I'm sure we'll Holly Cyborg.
It's happening.
It's interesting.
I'll tell you what.
Nobody has more composed or composure.
Nobody has more composure in their Instagram videos.
Then Holly,
she's the most composure.
She's like,
when she says professional,
Cyborg's been saying that.
I haven't been tested.
She's a politician.
I'd actually,
I've been tested nine times.
She's been tested eight times,
so some of us are out here training not worrying about these.
Fantastic.
It's so like,
thank you.
Thank you and have a good thank you.
We're ready to head kick a pitch.
I love Paul even says in direct contrast to her fucking back flips.
She's a politician,
had gigs and shit.
It's like a politician.
Very smart man.
Very calm and smooth and she's like a real all American girl.
Like you look at Holly Holm.
I mean she got freckles and shit.
She's pretty,
she looks like an all American head kicker and Pete Cyborg in for the tough.
If it's tough,
if she beats Cyborg to me,
she's number one of all time.
She'd beat Ronda and her prime right now.
She'd beat Cyborg in her prime.
What are we doing?
I know she had those rough logs show where you should take.
I know.
Listen,
Misha Tate strangled her and she was still punching in the air while she was
going unconscious.
Yeah.
That's how savage Holly Holm is.
I know.
It's such a great matchup.
You should take,
did get her and me.
She got her in the fifth round of a fight.
She was losing,
losing.
Took her back and put it asleep.
I'm going to miss your tape fans.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Fan.
But she's retired.
Yup.
She didn't wanna do anything about Holly Cyborg,
you know,
but it's that Holly Cyborg.
Yeah.
I wonder what kind of numbers that does cause that.
That's your headline on there right now because you know,
dump cruises off.
Well,
it's going to show you the power of a like top flight women's MMA fights and
then there's the,
you know,
there's the cyborg aspect.
Like people tune in,
she's like a cultural icon sort of a thing.
Like people will tune in to see you.
Like,
oh,
that cyborg check.
She's scared.
Yeah.
Does it scares either and scary being me.
Not physically scary.
Scary the way she destroys violent,
very violent,
violent and very technical.
Her last fight wasn't that violent,
but she wanted to show most of his fighting a crazy,
I mean zombies talking about something.
I'm Tonya evenger.
She's she.
She didn't give a fuck.
She was throwing a mom.
I don't know.
I call her mom,
but she's tough as fuck.
Had Mom bod and also would not go away like that if you were watching like a
youtube or a lot,
it wouldn't even be on youtube.
They pull it from youtube,
like a live leak outside of a bar and Kentucky I think worse.
She some chick gets up,
puts her fucking cigarette down and rolls up the sleeve.
Flannel shirt,
probably wearing your shirt,
the very shirt you're wearing and just throws haymakers on some check and she's
got her since she's fucking drop and Moitai elbows on her,
but she keeps getting mom.
She'd be like the Kimbo slice soccer moms in the backyard.
Brawls.
She's a tough,
tough woman.
She's as tough as you say,
an animal.
I enjoyed that fight because of her.
I agree.
She made the fire.
She made the fire chief.
She fucking had some whistling shots swinging by Cyborgs Chin.
She didn't plan for it.
Look it.
She took it.
She took it hard.
She was going for it.
That's off.
Took a fight that a lot of people didn't want.
No one wants that fight.
Yeah.
I mean look at fucking and Germane to random.
He said,
Nah,
I'm good.
You can keep your title shot fighting her if she's done serious before it.
Yeah,
but she tests clean now.
I don't care.
I'm out.
Not,
not recently enough.
Nope.
No.
You got to get her.
Test her again like 10 years.
Yeah,
true.
Every day for 10 years.
Then we'll draw me said,
fuck is this.
I love that Cyborg fight though.
I do too,
but I wanted to see what number is.
It does see Germane to random.
He is a very tactical Stryker.
That's why I thought her versus Cyborg would be interesting.
I mean Jermaine,
Jermaine to random.
He fought a man.
That's how crazy scary Cyborg is.
Germane,
fought a man and k owed him this video of you if watch it.
She's like,
I'll fight a man,
but I don't know.
I just,
I'm often drawn to me trains when you give up the belt we say not fuck it.
She just,
she's too much.
Well I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a fan of her talent.
She's a very talented fighter but she should have been chipping in the first
place.
I agree.
Paul.
He beat her and I think she should have been penalized for sure.
For at least one of those.
After the bell shot 100%.
She landed two after the bell shots.
One of them was devastating.
Like she really rocked Holly,
beat her.
I think Holly beat her.
I think uh,
you got to take into consideration how,
what scoring system they were using back then.
Cause I do not think that they were using the new MMA school.
It's also New York Early Day New York.
When I say early day,
like six months ago.
I think the refereeing,
I mean I think the refereeing could have been better because I do think she
should have been penalized for those shots after the bill.
And when Holly head kicked her,
that was one of the most significant moments in the fight.
The other most significant moment of fighters and Holly dropped with a straight
left hand.
Yeah.
So those are two giant moments in the fight.
And they were both on Holly side.
And then there was the two shots after the bell,
which you could conceivably penalize her for at least one you have to do for
one.
And that's what I thought.
Holding on the fight.
Yeah,
I would,
I would agree with you.
I would agree with you because other than that,
Holly did the most damage in the fight for sure.
But during demanding Germain,
de Randamie was controlling the action,
the beginning of the fight until Holly landed that question mark kick.
I'm Funko maybe a question mark.
It cause a beautiful Kik.